c'est la onzième semaine québécoise des
marchés publics qui tire à sa fin
aujourd'hui plus de 60 activités étaient
offertes aux consommateurs qui sont
venus faire le plein de fruits de
légumes dans les différents marchés
la province et pour faire le point nous
accueillons la nutritionniste et pas
parole de la semaine québécoise des
marchés publics julie aubé merci
beaucoup julio b d'être avec nous
méritons l'invitation ça nous fait
plaisir
depuis le 8 ou vous sillonnez donc les
marchés publics au québec va tourner
commencé à amqui et là ça va se terminer
à l'île-des-soeurs quel est votre bilan
en fait un bilan qui est réjouissant
parce que j'ai rencontrés pendant deux
jours des gens qui sont sur les marchés
qui sont l'ex ont fière de l'être qui
ont leur marché à coeur qui
s'approvisionnent localement de produits
de qualité de proximité donc très
réjouissant on joue on souhaite juste
amener encore plus de gens dans le
mouvement pour découvrir les marchés
puis les savourer oui est ce que vous
sentez un engouement des québécois on en
parle de plus en plus de manger
localement d'aller dans les marchés
publics que davantage de fraîcheur
connaître nos producteurs est ce que
vous sentez cet engouement actuel oui
absolument surtout que je reviens de
disney à vous j'ai rencontré les gens
qui sont sur les marchés publics amp
d'intelligent qui sont déjà convaincus
qu'ils sont là mais on le sent un
engouement
on sent aussi que des gens qui vont
rencontrer un paquet d'obstacles dans le
fond ça peut être des fois les horaires
ça peut être une perception de prix elle
ça peut être que le fait d'avoir
beaucoup de choses en même temps donc il
ya toutes sortes d'obstacles mais on se
rend compte que la formule des marchés
bien les différentes d'un marché à
l'autre il ya toujours moyen de
s'adapter aux gens finalement des fois
autour de chez nous il ya des horaires
ont parlé des marchés en a qui sont deux
jours il en existe en deux soirs il ya
moyen de trouver des marchés qui
concorde avec notre horaire des
quantités qui concorde avec la grandeur
de notre famille donc les moyens de
convaincre un grand paquet de gens qui
est ça répond aux besoins
oui vous avez parler d'adaptation la
cèze pour nos producteurs producteurs de
légumes par exemple on sait que le
prétend a été froid frisquet men
davantage de pluie quel impact
actuellement sa hausse sur les fruits
légumes et également sur le prix qu
est-ce que vous avez remarqué d'abord
d'être très variable selon les types de
fruits et légumes ainsi que selon les
régions il ya des régions qui ont comme
réussi à rattraper leur retard d'autres
où l'on peut accuse un certain retard
selon les deux fruits selon les types de
légumes mais je dirais que ce pourrait à
la question
oui en fait moi je pendant qu'on est en
pleine saison d'abondance
c'est même abordable d'aller au marché
cherchait ses fruits et ses légumes ces
aliments de base c'est maintenant que ça
se passe les produits sont nombreux sont
allés chanson ferait donc c'est le temps
de remplir nos assiettes maintenant de
ses produits lors des saisons aussi d'y
penser pour les mois les plus froids qui
s'en viennent parce que vous savez que
des fois à l'hiver on entend parler d'un
style rigdzin choux fleurs qui ornent
depuis fin mars et vous avez de la suite
d'analysés parce que j'allais voulons
aussi là dessus
le fameux céleri à 6 dollars parce qu'on
a dit qu'avec toutes sortes de vertus
les gens recommencent à acheter
davantage de céleri j'en avais vu aussi
des hausses de prix au mois de juin je
passe la hausse de 17% ou à peu près
alors la saison estivale on voit ses
prix redescendent c'est quand même sur
la bonne nouvelle mais c'est l'abondance
donc tout est prêt tout est là moi
j'aimais quand même les gens défi de
trouver un style réaliste dollar sur un
marché public en ce moment en cette
saison si donc tu as congèle bien faire
des réserves qui fait la même chose pour
le maïs pour les broccolis là l'hiver
ils seront qu'une écemment locos les
produits là donc c'est vraiment temps
d'en profiter et de l'autre c'est qu'on
marchés publics
c'est le producteur qui fait que son
prix donc on est assurés payer le juste
prix qui est intéressant aussi
on ne l'avantagent d'avoir un contact
direct avec le marchand avec
l'agriculteur la retenant gourmande pas
d'intermédiaire
c'est ce qu'on a dit c'est ce qu'on a
dit à quelques mois c'est que souvent le
prix était plus élevé en raison donc de
cet intermédiaire qui pouvait lui aussi
des prix alors l'on va chercher
directement au producteur est certain
que les intermédiaires se plante hôte
une petite partie du dollar puisque il
ya du transport de l'entreposage les
salaires de ces gens là donc quand on
achète directement du producteur
c'est lui qui fait que son prix on
s'assure de payer un juste prix moi je
suis fier de payer un juste prix qui
représente le travail du producteur
mais au-delà de ça on a des échanges on
apprend est le producteur peut nous
donner des idées de cuisine pour ses
produits le comment les conserver
comment les apprêter c'est super
inspirant aussi au delà de la fraîcheur
on a parlé de la fraîcheur mais c'est
des aliments de base qu'on ramène à la
maison les aliments de base à la maison
ça nous influence à cuisiner et cuisiner
à partir d'aliments de base non
seulement c'est une des meilleures
choses pour notre santé mais aussi c'est
moins cher que de s'approvisionner après
un aliment transformé ultra transformer
ou en produits qui viennent de la
restauration rapide par exemple donc
l'impact sur le prix on va le chercher
aussi parce qu'on cuisine d'avant
on est inspirée mais une petite ombre au
tableau je regardais notamment cette
semaine des résidus de pesticides
parce que souvent on se dit hostile aux
états unis alors ce sont les façons de
faire
chez nos voisins du sud l'on s'est rendu
compte qu'ils avaient des résidus des
pesticides même sur les frais du québec
est-ce que ça ce que ça peu inquiété
c'est les consommateurs quel impact ça
peut avoir sur les gens ça ne veut faire
passer un peu inquiété je pense que
c'est une bonne chose de s'en préoccuper
8,5 de se tenir informés sur la façon
que nos aliments sont produits chose
certaine faut pas que ça nous empêche de
remplir mon assiette de fruits et des
légumes ça reste une chose importante à
faire pour sa santé
mais je pense que ça souligne aussi
davantage de s'approvisionner dans un
endroit comme un marché public puisqu'on
peut poser des questions on peut avoir
un échange autour de ces questions là
avec les agriculteurs se faire rassurer
et se faire expliquer des méthodes d
pourquoi et je pense que ça on n'a pas
nécessairement dans d'autres façons de
s'approvisionner en plus grande surface
puis ce lien là est important ce dernier
une confiance aussi un dialogue avec le
producteur absolument absolument
médiation sont les bienvenus quand on
est aux marchés publics les gens qui
veulent discuter avec nous cet échange
les centrales il fait partie et fait
partie de l'expérience donc à
l'invitation est lancée
transformez votre approvisionnement en
expérience en commençant par le marché
puis l'expérience va se poursuivre
jusque là
l'invitation est lancée au centre de la
démarche et julie aubé nutritionniste
porte parole de la semaine québécoise
des marchés publics merci beaucoup
les airs